I'm George Smith and I'm one of the
recipients of the chemistry prize in
2018 well originally I would say that I
had a passion for like nature especially
animals my apparently I broke my parents
and going to the Bronx Zoo and stood for
like half an hour watching alligators
and crocodiles that never moved and they
they needed to have a lot of patience
with me in 1949 when I was 8 years old
we went on a vacation in Maine in the
northeast of the United States and the
place was like alive with snakes and I
caught my first snake a green snake and
paraded into the living room where my
mother was entertaining a tea party of
the very sort of like proper ladies of
the neighborhood who appropriately
screeched and so on and I became very
interested in snakes at that point and
in fact our family lived in Japan during
the Korean War from 1952 to 1919 52 to
1954 and I and a friend whose name I've
long since forgotten were both lovers of
snakes and we there were so many
wonderful snakes in Japan at the time so
I was I thought I was going to be a
herpetologist when when I grew up and I
would have I think except that my
college having for college had only
three biology professors and all of them
were selling molecular biologist and no
one was you know anything like a
herpetologist so actually professionally
I abandoned my herpetology and I became
a molecular biologist
Oh my parents irrelevant in many ways
that scientifically I would say my
father was very influential because he
was an army officer he was he was kind
of he was in the branch we call ordnance
which is like supplies it's kind of like
the business part of the army but he was
curious about everything for example
when we lived in Japan every weekend we
he would be taking us on an adventure in
the neighborhood out off the army base
where we lived and using sign language
and expressions and so on to converse
with like a farmer like peanut farmer or
something like that we like so many
times be invited for tea inside
someone's house he was just extremely
outgoing and curious about everything
and especially about he went to West
Point which is our military academy and
that's kind of like a technical
education it's like an engineering
education and so he was particularly
interested in science engineering things
like that so I I think that that was
very influential in in my upbringing as
far my science upbringing and being
something that really encouraged that
kind of of curiosity and interest in and
how the world works like how things work
that that was that was one of his big
things he would understand how you know
gadgets worked and I think I inherited
or not genetically but I I was
encouraged to have that that kind of
habit of mine when when from my father
so that was certainly a big part also my
father was in the army
and in my as I became politically active
or politically aware in the 1960s the
war in Vietnam was a big part and my
parents
despite the fact that they were an army
family turned against the war in Vietnam
and this is a very I think perhaps
unusual upbringing and in the army so
dad that had quite a bit of influence on
me you know if I had to say the thing
that has given me most pleasure over the
years is kind of like workmanship in the
laboratory like gel electrophoresis
actually my postdoctoral advisor who's
also a Nobel laureate Oliver Smithies
invented gel electrophoresis well any
molecular biologist uses it all the time
so but to me designing how exactly how
you would load the samples in what order
trying to trying to design it so that so
that the results would be would be
really striking that was really
important to me I took such great
pleasure in the little tiny triumphs of
a two hours of work I would say that
that was really important to me of
course
I it was very exciting when sometimes I
might have some insight that I thought
was a breakthrough or thought it was an
aha moment those were very exciting too
and those were those were rare and the
the delight in workmanship in the
laboratory was a constant pleasure to me
a constant scientific pleasure to me
[Music]
well I think it's very important in in
many ways for one thing is mentors
health help students and early career
scientists make their thoughts sharper
more concrete they can also be a force
of conservatism about their science so
they also have to learn from their
mentors to not pay not to worship their
mentors and not to pay attention you
know not to think that their mentors
word is is gospel because sometimes the
mentors are going to give them advice
that'd be probably in the long run
better to ignore I think that's
something that it's very important for a
mentor to get across to an early career
scientist a student a postdoc etc that
you know you should a scientist needs to
be skeptical about everything that I
think is a very important lesson for for
for scientists to learn they have to be
skeptical about everything not to the
point that it did it that it immobilizes
them but to a point where where
everything has to be looked on as
provisional everything in sciences has
to be looked on as provisional I think
this is a habit of thought that is
really important in science a mentor
also of course serves as a role model it
would be good to be a mentor that
upholds standards of decent behavior and
and morality and the conduct of science
I mean that for example that you are
that you not don't be a role model
that's like a cutthroat that cuts down
in competitors or it looks on science as
fundamentally a competitive enterprise
because I don't think it is I mean
science is scientists lurches by a
community of scientists community
their ideas with each other
fundamentally that's the that's the
nourishment of science and I think that
I think that mentors oh it to their
protegees to value this above all else
in in science so how about me my a good
role model well you know I said that I
think that a scientists need to foster
the attitude of being skeptical about
everything so I think everyone should be
skeptical about his or her own behavior
and so I think that maybe I'm a harsh
critic of myself and I don't I don't
value uh valorized my own behavior as a
as a role model I I aspire to be a good
role model but no one really reaches his
or her aspirations
[Music]
I heard the news about the prize well it
came at 4:30 in the morning in Columbia
Missouri where we live and actually I
have kind of sort of the difficulty
sleeping through the night that many old
people do have and so I was actually had
come downstairs around 10 after 4:00 to
start the coffee for the morning and the
phone rang and my wife answered it
upstairs in the bedroom and apparently
the call was well stand by for a very
important call from Stockholm at which
point the line went dead and then the
call came through again she answered it
again and the same message and she
called downstairs this is a call from
Stockholm I think you better get it so I
did that's how I learned about it when I
got this call I was very surprised now I
I do want to say that I knew that I was
one of the plunders of people that was
on the radar of the chemistry committee
and that's because I was invited to a
conference and the hundredth year
anniversary of the chemistry prize in
2001 to a conference in honor of that
anniversary they were just very few
participants in the conference maybe 20
or 30 or something like that
and all of us were invited to the
ceremony and to the banquet after fir'd
so I kind of know what what you know
what the ceremony is going to be like
although not from the point of view and
act of an actual laureate but that also
alerted me that it was pretty likely
that I was on the
radar of the chemistry committee so it
did come as a surprise 17 years later
because I thought the time had long
since passed so it wasn't an you know a
bolt out of the blue but it was a big
surprise because I had long since
thought that there that this was the
time and past
to be a prize winner when you're retired
because I retired from my university
three years ago and I'm not doing much
science anymore
so it is it is something to look back
with with pleasure and pride that that
this has this word has come I'm gonna
say in my lecture that I feel that I'm
taking it I'm accepting the prize as a
representative the science community
that I that I belong to because many
people in this community could equally
get this prize but it certainly is an
honor that I look upon with pleasure
also I think that my family looks on it
was even more pleasure than I do and I
should add that this is the first Nobel
Prize for my University of public
university of the University of Missouri
and it is a great honor to my University
and so I think all three of those are
things that give me pleasure my own
pleasure and the vicarious pleasure on
the part of my family and my University
and my science community
[Music]
in countless ways the science community
is nurtured is depends for its support
on the wider community of society as a
whole
it depends crucially of course on the
schools that educate our children some
of whom will eventually end up in as
part of the professional scientific
community their teachers
it depends crucially our colleges and
universities especially the public
colleges and universities including my
own University the University of
Missouri where children get their
further education and that support the
local science communities of which I was
a member in the at the University of
Missouri for 40 years these are very
important and also science the
well-being of science depends critically
on institution public institutions like
in the United States the National
Science Foundation the National
Institutes of Health which supported my
research and similar institutions in
other countries for example the Medical
Research Council in the UK our science
communities depends on public
institutions supported by the people as
a whole for critical financial support
and for you know being if we're
persuading people as a whole that this
is really an important part of our
culture and the end economy that's what
we've absolutely depend on that kind of
broad society support and university
support is part of that
you know it's a perpetual problem in
science education really in education in
general but specifically in science
education is what do we teach our young
people to try to ensure as well as we
can that they could be successful in
science afterwards so do we teach them
the specific technical skills that we
ourselves depended on that's a that's a
question that teachers often have have
to have to grapple with and they're two
sides of that one thing is I think that
students really need to understand
specifically and concretely
what what physical things support our
theories about nature what results
what's what concrete results are behind
what we think of as our knowledge about
nature so we probably the students
really should learn about the some of
the nitty-gritty of experimental science
how we carry out experiments and how we
look at the data and how we deal with
the fact that inevitably data are messy
and it's not so clear-cut it's as if it
we're in a textbook we have to I think
educate students to be sophisticated
about the relationship between physical
findings and the interpretations that we
give about those physical findings I
think that's really critical and I think
also we that students should learn about
the fundamental ideas the fundamental
theories theoretical understanding that
underlies their the science that they're
learning they
they need to be educated in the science
culture in which they are in in which
they are learning and as I've tried to
say before also they need to learn to be
skeptical about that culture that it is
not the last word and nothing in
scientists the last word about anything
they need to be skeptical about about
that culture as well these are all
things that I think a teacher
is has a sacred duty to to pass on to to
help to pass on to students as well as
he or she can do it
[Music]
so I'm often asked about the the
applications of my work and and what
their meaning is and so my co-winner
great greg winter went on to use the
phage display idea in very imaginative
ways not just him but of course his
whole whole group and other groups that
are similar groups carrying out similar
research use this in very imaginative
ways that have turned out to be
important for developing new medicines
and a good example and a commonly cited
example in the context of this surprise
is of this prize is the is Humira which
is a medicine developed partly using
phage display technology not not by me
but that was but that has that that's an
example of something that has come from
this I'm not sure that I would say that
I myself most proud of that to me a
phage display the technology that I
developed I saw that that my vision at
the time as it matured over a few years
was that it would make a technologically
very productive technology available
broadly and cheaply and without very
strong technical background required
without the high demands technological
demands available widely to researchers
all over the world and that is a I think
that it's it is a an aspiration that has
been partly met because certainly many
people have used phage display in
ordinary laboratories not in heavily
funded industry laboratories or academic
laboratories but in very ordinary
laboratories as my laboratory what was
itself did not doesn't have a lot of
money to spare but this was a technology
that could be
carried out by such a laboratory I that
was a big aspiration of mine I think it
is one that has been partly fulfilled
[Music]
and so I mentioned before that I've been
retired for for three years and I'm not
I have an abandoned science altogether I
still go to lab meetings for a couple of
collaborators at the University every
week or most weeks and I go to the many
of the seminars in my my former
department which wasn't chemistry by the
way it was biology I'm a biologist so I
it's not that I've abandoned science
altogether but I also have continued a
long-standing interest in my life in I
would say social justice and human
rights that has I mean it I would say
that it started in the 1960s when I was
a war resistor fan during the Vietnam
War and has continued on and off since
then so that's become a very important
part of my life human rights and social
justice in the United States for example
a major effort that that my wife Margie
sable and I are involved in is the fight
for a just health care system in our
country one that is universally
available to all citizens and that that
does not bankrupt people that happen to
get sick so that that would be an iconic
social justice issue and that kind of
issue is what engages me more now in my
retirement life
well it would be funny to me except that
I've known many Nobel laureates and I
know about many of the prizes I told you
that I was I was at the ceremony in 2001
there was no Nobel Prize in biology yet
clearly biology is an iconic scientific
enterprise and especially in ever since
Darwin really it's like it is a landmark
scientific enterprise in the 20th
century right from the beginning of the
20th century when when Darwin was fully
accepted by the biological community and
since chemistry is deeply and deeply
involved in biology it is pretty natural
that many of the that the prizes in
chemistry that involved biological
subjects are awarded to people who would
identify themselves as biologists and
also there really applies to physics as
well because several of the physics
prizes I think Oh the their their
salience to the fact that they have led
to applications in biological scientists
so yes I think that that I I think that
it's pretty natural that prizes go to
biologists from both chemistry
especially chemistry but also physics to
not just to make up but but did the fact
that there's no biology prize and also
Barbara McClintock who was amazed
geneticist got the Prize in Physiology
and medicine and who could be more of a
biologist than Barbara McClintock so the
prize don't fall into the neat
categories that Nobel envisioned in his
in his will
and I would imagine that Alfred Nobel
would be very pleased that that's the
case
[Music]
a phage is a virus that infects bacteria
and grows to huge numbers and can be
grown to huge numbers very cheaply so it
is a very convenient laboratory organism
to work for for experimenters to work
with so fate display tries to harness
this this natural device for for
searching through huge libraries of
structures tens of billions of
structures for structures that have a
particular activity that that the
experimenter wants they for some
experimental end as for example
something that would some structure that
would bind to a receptor involved in
cancer or autoimmune disease or
something like that and that might be
used as an intervention for that for
that disease so it's a it's a
technologically pretty simple and and
powerful yet powerful way of searching
through enormous and enormous
collections of structures for very rare
structures that have a desired activity
[Music]